hey again you guys
welcome back to my flickers of fear show
as i mentioned on the last one this is
going to be my new series
where i'm just going to be talking about
old and new horror movies
that i watched in any particular week
ones that i didn't really think
tom would care about seeing uh but ones
that i had been wanting to see or
you know ones that have been recommended
and that i had put on my list
so let's get on with it so as if the
first
movie in this series wasn't depressing
and shocking enough
i decided to just go whole hog on this
one
another movie that i've been wanting to
see for a very long time weirdly this is
how
this kind of came about so the other day
when i decided to watch this movie
because this movie uh it's threads
by the way from 1984. it had been on
shutter for quite a while
i had heard about it i didn't see it
back when it came out but it i knew it
by reputation
so you know the other day i was kind of
like
i was having kind of a crappy day and i
was kind of like you know
you know what might make me feel better
watching a movie that's really really
grim and depressing
that's about a nuclear holocaust
where everybody dies that's what i think
would make me feel better so
i sat down on shutter and watched
threads
now i'm sure uh
my british viewers will know about
threads it seems like everybody knows
about that it's like an infamous film
maybe american one's not so familiar
however if you
are a child of the 70s or the 80s in the
united states you will probably be
familiar with a little 1983
tv movie called the day after which
depicted uh a nuclear war in its
aftermath
uh which in the 80s a very uh a pretty
likely scenario it's
actually probably still pretty a pretty
likely scenario we just don't
think about it as much i guess but back
in the 80s it was very very much in
the front of the public consciousness
there was a lot of like armageddon type
stuff that came out
all of which was rather horrifying so i
will say that i did see the day after
i believe it was on abc i want to say i
remember
some things about it and i remember it
being pretty gruesome and pretty
upsetting and scary
i think i remember more that you know
being in school the next day
because i think i was in fifth grade i
think it was about 11 when it came out
and everybody talking about it because
everybody had watched it
and um so i remember my fifth grade
teacher you know kind of fielding
questions about it and everybody being
like really really worried now about uh
you know nuclear wars the 80s kids a few
guys grew up in the 80s
and you kind of you know came to a you
know a formidable age like in the early
mid 1980s
uh threat of nuclear war was a very very
it seemed a very real possibility
and uh so a lot of the media at the time
kind of reflected that
now as i said i don't remember a great
deal about the day after i be i remember
it being like a decent movie and it did
have some horrific imagery in it that
was you know
somewhat realistically based but i think
what the problem that the day after
maybe had
was that it attempted to go a little bit
to
quote-unquote hollywood in the sense
that it had
some actors in it that were actually
kind of well-known at the time i mean
even though i was only 11 like i
recognized
a lot of the actors in it jobeth
williams was in it she had just been in
poltergeist the year before
um you know jason robards was in it
steve guttenberg was in it for christ's
sake
so it wasn't like you were seeing mr and
mrs joe nobody
you know getting blown away in a nuclear
holocaust it's like you were seeing
famous people
who you knew were probably going to die
but it was fake you know what i mean so
i do
feel like having recognizable actors in
it sort of worked against
it in a way um i also feel
like and like i said please correct me
if i'm wrong because i haven't seen it
in a very long time
but i do think that as grim as the day
after was
and as horrifying as it was and it was
i'm not saying that it wasn't it did
have at least a little bit
of you know oh did the americans we're
all going to pull together and you know
we're going to farm now and we have
gumption
and you know everything it's like
everything sucks but it'll be okay there
was like a little bit of hope
whereas threads uh which was also made
for
television but in the uk gave its
viewers
no such comfort so i feel like it's
basically that old cliche
of the day after being like
yeah we're gonna make this really grim
realistic movie
about a nuclear apocalypse and then
threads in the uk said kindly hold my
logger
so threads was made in 1984
and as i said a lot of people have said
it's kind of like the british answer to
the day after because it came about
about a year
a year and a few months after but the
thing about it was that
it was actually made not so much in
response to the day after
but it was made because the bbc uh they
had actually
commissioned this film way the [ __ ] back
in 1965
which was called the war game and it was
very much
like threads is now it was a docudrama
in the sense that
it had some documentary type aspects to
it
but it was essentially like a
reenactment as realistic as possible
of what a nuclear war and its aftermath
would look like
now the war game uh was as i said was
made by the bbc or commissioned by the
bbc but then when it was kind of shown
to you know the the board or whoever uh
they were kind of like yeah we can't
show that which
i don't know that's very funny to me
it's like uh make a really realistic
movie about the aftermath of a nuclear
war then you show it to him you're like
we can't show that well they said they
couldn't show it because they were
afraid that everyone would commit
suicide after one not everyone but that
a lot of people would commit suicides
after it it's like well we can't be
responsible for that
but uh so they didn't show it i don't
think they actually showed it on british
tv until you know probably decades later
but whoever was running the bbc in the
80s uh had actually saw the war game and
knew that it hadn't ever aired
and was like man we need to do another
thing like that nowadays we'll do it
contemporary uh so let's make one like
that so we'll show it on uh
bbc now the writer of this movie uh
is barry hines now if you know anything
about british cinema
um you'll know that barry hines uh he
wrote many other things too
but he also probably best known for
writing the novel
a kestrel for a knave which uh the was
the basis of the
classic ken loach film kess
uh i've both read the book and seen the
movie uh they're both
amazing classics of british literature
classic of british cinema
and if you haven't seen them and if you
really like british cinema then you
probably
should you know kess and the novel that
it was based on
very very grim uh you know barry hines
kind of
very well known as being like a champion
of the working class showing their
struggles
so um he was actually a very good writer
to get uh
you know to get involved in this project
uh you know the making of threads
now the director of it was mick jackson
uh he had done
some tv and things like that prior uh
interestingly after threads
he went on he made some more movies
and the two that i found the most
interesting he actually made a couple of
kind of big budget like hollywood type
movies
he was the director of la story with
steve martin if you guys remember that
one
that was from 87 i want to say and he
also is the director of the bodyguard
with kevin costner and whitney houston
so if you've seen those movies threads
is nothing like that
so don't go into this expecting to be
some [ __ ] walk in the park
because it's not i'm gonna tell you
right now threads a lot of people
particularly in the uk that saw it when
they were kids or teenagers
said this was the most horrifying and
still is the most horrifying film
they've ever seen
just because it was something that could
really happen
it was completely realistic and it just
made them depressed and horrified and
they just have never seen anything like
you know and images from it are like
burned into their retinas and i can
totally totally see that
because this movie you really really
have to be
in the right mindset to want to watch
this movie because it is not fun
there is no happiness there is no joy
there is no hope there is no nothing
this movie starts out grim and just gets
[ __ ] grimmer and grim is just the
non-stop
descent into complete and utter
despair and i mean it is you will
probably feel like ill
after watching it or at least will be
like man just [ __ ]
just kill me this is terrible but i will
say
in its defense i will say that if you're
in a real real bad mood
maybe this is at least how i reacted
because like i said i've had kind of a
crappy day when i decided to watch this
because i'm
like perverse like that but so when i
decided to watch this
and after it was over i was kind of like
wow that was probably one of the most
depressing things i've ever seen but i
kind of feel better because
you know i got problems but i don't have
any problems like those people have
[ __ ] problems i
[ __ ] all right so as i said threads
don't go into it expecting it to be
like a horror movie or even like a
regular narrative movie it does have
characters and it does have you know
situations and things that are happening
but it's not really structured like
a standard movie it's more like as i
said it's generally called a docudrama
so it would essentially be like
something you might see
you know back in the good old days when
you know the discovery channel and
history channel actually showed
real [ __ ] instead of just being all
bigfoot shows
um and ghost hunting so so it has like
some documentary style
you know aspects to it you know this
this many megatons
fell on the thing and you know this is
what would happen 10 years later
um you know so it has that kind of stuff
giving you statistics
but then the rest of it is kind of like
a reenactment
showing exactly what would happen to a
regular
city in the uk um if this ever were to
come to pass
so this uh is set in sheffield
uh an industrial city and it kind of
revolves around a couple of families
i don't really want to say that there's
main characters like i said characters
are not really the point of this the
point of this
docudrama the point of this film was to
show
people and to get them to emotionally
react to this is
what a nuclear war would be like can we
please uh like all do something to never
ever have this happen
because it's pretty much the most
horrifying thing you can imagine
so it's you know in that sense i don't
really like to use the word polemic
because it sounds very judgy
but it does have an agenda and um it is
very very successful in you know getting
that across
in getting across that watching this
should be like yeah we should never
do that because that would be the
[ __ ] worst thing ever so this follows
essentially two families kind of the
main characters if you want to call them
that
are sort of like a young couple they're
in their you know their teens or their
early 20s
um jimmy and ruth and at the very
beginning of the movie um you see them
in the car and they're kind of talking
about
you know [ __ ] that people like that in a
kind of a working-class town talk about
and uh it comes to pass that ruth is
pregnant
so uh over the course like jimmy kind of
decides to even though he's very young
decides to kind of step up and do the
right thing oh you know we'll get
married you know we'll both of our
families are going to help out and we'll
get a flat and we'll raise the baby
it'll be
awesome now i think that one of the most
effective
things about this movie and one of the
most heartbreaking things about this
movie even though you don't really get
to know any of the characters
other than just regular ass people which
in a way makes them more relatable
in a sense because it's just kind of
like people like acquaintances that you
know you don't know a great deal about
them
you as the viewer know that about
halfway through this movie
the [ __ ] nuclear bomb is gonna fall
and everything's gonna go to [ __ ]
and so all of the stuff that you know
all the worries that these characters
have in the first half of the movie are
not going to mean
anything everything that they're talking
about is completely meaningless
and i think that that drives the point
home really really well because they
don't
harp on it they don't but it's just i
think the realism in the first half
you know where you're just interacting
with the characters you're just kind of
hanging out with them
another thing i like about it too is
that they're not really talking about
the escalating tensions it's just kind
of like very very much in the background
you see you know somebody reading a
newspaper or somebody watching a news
broadcast or something like that
about escalating tensions between the us
and the soviet union um you know the
soviet union has moved
nukes into iran like against a treaty
and like you know u.s
is threatening nuclear strikes unless
they take them out by a certain time
period the time period passes
now all this kind of stuff is going on
so it just keeps like ramping up and up
but the thing about it is that as what
would happen in real life which like i
said which is what makes this so scary
is that all the characters they're not
oblivious
they see that it's going on like i said
they see it on the news they read you
know
they even have like jimmy and his friend
like in the pub kind of talking about it
at one point like oh this
looks bad you know but it seems like
it's such a big
it's far away it's such a big problem
and
they're just kind of like well you can't
really do anything about it except
kind of go about your life and hope for
the best and that's exactly what these
people are doing
and i think that that's what makes this
again so frightening and so relatable
is that that's exactly what most people
are doing because the threat of a
nuclear war and you know
you know i i know i lived through the
[ __ ] in the 80s when you know you had
drills where you had to like climb at
your desk and all this other kind of
stuff because you know the bombs are
following him as if that would save you
but you know it's just kind of it's
the enormity of it you can't really wrap
your head around it
so you know there's nothing you
personally as a little
you know insignificant person can do to
prevent it or stop
it so it's almost kind of like you like
you can't worry about it it's just too
much for your brain to handle
it's like if you worry about it then you
might as well just kill yourself because
there's nothing you can do and i think
that there's you know at one point in
the movie as i said jimmy and his friend
are in the pub
and um you know it's kind of on the news
like how the tensions are escalating and
everybody kind of gets quiet in the pub
like oh man maybe this is going to be
worse than we thought
i but the thing is nobody really thinks
that
the worst is actually going to happen i
mean you as a viewer know that the worst
is going to happen obviously because
that's what you're watching this movie
for but you know the characters don't
know but they still think something's
bad
but you never think it's going to be as
bad as it turns out so the two
characters are kind of having this
discussion
and jimmy's like well you know aren't
you worried about her don't you care and
you know his friend is like yeah i care
but you know there's nothing i can do
about it and
you know if it does happen i at least
you know want to be drunk or having a
good time or you know use the most of my
time to like have fun you know because
what else can you do
except just keep on trucking and you
know just hope it doesn't happen so
that's kind of what all the characters
are doing
so they're making all these plans that
you know there's these little scenes
where
you know uh where jimmy and ruth are in
their new flat and they're scraping off
the ugly old wallpaper
you know because she's pregnant and
they're gonna you know set up their
nursery and everything and you know that
it's just all for nothing and it's just
really really sad so then about as i
said probably about the midpoint of the
movie this is about a two hour uh film a
little under two hours i believe it is
midpoint of the movie uh you get the
mushroom cloud that you've all been
waiting for which that's kind of a
[ __ ] up way of saying it but
yeah essentially after that it's just
oh my god this movie is just
unrelentingly
bleak just the worst [ __ ] [ __ ]
and the thing about it is that this
movie
they did a year of research they
consulted
government officials they consulted
scientists they consulted everybody
everybody that knew
anything about nuclear war about its
long-term effects about its short-term
effects about what would happen you know
everything they did a lot of homework on
this one so
they wanted this to be as realistic as
possible they didn't want anything
exaggerated they obviously wanted to
make a point
but they didn't want to have to blow
anything out of proportion
you know forgive my use of words to make
that point
now interestingly i think though that as
grim and [ __ ] bleak as this movie is
they might have undersold it just a
little bit um
you know what i mean just in the sense
that this is horrific
but if it happened in real life it would
be even more horrific so
that's a cheerful thought if you watch
this just keep that in mind
but yeah so they did a lot of homework
to get this as realistic as possible so
basically what happens the mushroom
cloud you know the one of the nukes like
explodes i can't remember like up in the
atmosphere um you know
what was it three thirty thousand
megatons i can't remember what it is now
it says like a you know there's text
crawl on there like saying what's going
on
how many people were killed in the
initial bombing um
how many people were killed by the
subsequent dust that went up
and uh things of that nature so yeah so
the whole [ __ ] neighborhood blown to
[ __ ] like all the windows are blown out
you know
obviously like a [ __ ] ton of people die
in the uh in the
initial blast and one thing that's great
about this movie if
that's kind of a weird way of putting it
i just realized but
one thing that's effective about this
movie let's put it that way
is that it's i think this was at the
time
the only movie to show the long-term
effects
of what a nuclear war would bring like a
you know a nuclear winter where all the
dust would go up into the atmosphere and
would essentially block out the sun
meaning that the earth would cool down
to a point where you know you couldn't
really grow
crops as effectively anymore the growing
season would be much shorter um you know
all the radiation would kind of poison
the soil down to a certain degree
so you know they were talking about it
you know it's not just the bombing it's
not just the
immediate effects but it's also you know
10 years down the line 20 years down the
line obviously
um you know there's going to be mass
starvation mass disease
you know so so it's not going to be a
fun time for anyone involved
over the whole planet it's going to
affect you whether the bombs hit
you or not so i like that it kind of
went into that
another thing that is very very
effective about this movie i feel like
too
is that as i said this isn't really
focused on characters it's focused on
the situation
it's focused on showing you you know
exactly what would happen
while giving you enough of relatable
just regular ass
people going about their regular ass
monday and lives
that you could see yourself in them you
know you didn't have to get to know them
you didn't have to
you know you was sad when they died but
you were just kind of like oh that guy i
love that guy you know it wasn't like
that
but it was just enough that that you
could make yourself a stand-in i guess
for the characters so they i think they
they hit that balance like really really
well so one thing that they do in this
which i think is super effective is that
some of the characters like after all
the [ __ ] starts to hit the fan
some of the characters disappear and you
never like hear from them again like so
ruth um you know the bombs like follow
their houses fall and everything like
that
um her parents i think her grandmother
ends up dying and that her parents
eventually end up dying you know
not i don't think from the initial
bombing but from uh you know radiation
sickness and various things that happen
in the subsequent days
and obviously people start starvation
the water's poisoned and all these other
things
so she actually ends up surviving and
because she's
pregnant she decides that she's going to
leave the house against the
advice of whatever authorities are
remaining and she's going to go
try to find jimmy well spoiler alert she
never does find jimmy and nobody ever
finds jimmy you don't find out if he's
dead if he's still alive somewhere
and i kind of like that because
that's exactly what it would be like and
i think the whole point of this movie
and the reason that it's called threads
which they kind of say at the beginning
because they're talking about you know
humanity being sort of like a tapestry
or like a spiderweb of all these
interconnecting
threads of you know people making things
for other people and you know we we all
like need each other to kind of
you know have a society and that once
some when some of those threads are
broken
it uh you know makes a lot much larger
impact than you might think
so i think that it's good that it showed
just these hanging threads
where you never find out what happened
because that's exactly what would happen
if this happened in real life
uh you know you don't find out where
jimmy was the last thing you see
is him he hit under a truck during the
initial blast with his friend
and then you know after kind of the
worst of it passes he runs out of the
truck and he's like i gotta find ruth
and then he takes off and you never
[ __ ] see him again and i kind of like
that they did that
another thing they do too is that they
also have aside from
you know kind of following the families
a little bit is they also have
these sort of i guess like civic
authority type uh people
and i guess they have like their
day-to-day jobs are kind of like other
type of jobs but they've also
taken these courses to you know
readiness courses for
you know in case of nuclear war you know
you're going to be activated like to do
this and that the other so they have
their little binders full of like all
the instructions
who they're supposed to call and what
they're supposed to do you're supposed
to check on
you know all the farming stuff you know
make sure that the stores are getting
all the food so people don't starve and
you got to make sure the clean water
about
so you know you got to make sure the
roads are you know this road remains
clear and all this other stuff so it's
those
people and they a bunch of them get
activated but these people
you know they're not dumb obviously and
they are trained but as i said earlier
no one you know people prepared for this
i mean they had contingency plans
i mean they had like i said they had a
whole binding of [ __ ] they were supposed
to do in these situations
but i don't think they were prepared for
the enormity of it how bad
it was um you know because they're just
human you can't
you can't really unless you're in that
scenario and
a scenario like that is just so outside
the bounds of what most people have ever
been through
that you can't imagine it you can't you
know you can't imagine how bad it could
be
so you know the lack of preparedness is
kind of an issue too so they have a
thing where there's a bunch of them
they get activated they take them down
to this kind of underground bunker that
they prepared but it wasn't even ready
that was just like bunk beds and like
some [ __ ] chemical toilets and [ __ ]
like that they had to throw in there at
the last minute
and the dudes are down there and they're
obviously trying to do the best they can
you know with their binders and their we
have all these numbers and this is the
person you call for this we gotta check
on this but it's like everything's
turning to [ __ ] everything is just
turning into chaos
um you know people are we're looting the
stores you know everyone's
they don't have any place to put bodies
they don't have any place to put
uh you know people that are breaking the
law looters um you know in the end they
just end up having to shoot them because
they don't know what else to do
um you know so so it's just kind of like
this escalating thing of chaos where
no one really knows everybody kind of
wants to do something to help but it's
just the problem is too big for them
and you can really see you know them
just getting more and more frustrated
and they're kind of like starting to
fight each other and they can't get
anybody else on the radio
and then they're kind of like you know
the the bunker where they are like
they're underneath the city hall and
like the city hall has been bombed and
like it's falling and they can't
you know get out and uh you know the air
is starting to get poisoned they're
running out of oxygen so they're kind of
flipping out and everything
and uh so they kind of follow them a
little bit too and i also like much in
the way that they did with the jimmy
character who just kind of like you know
ran off and then you never see him again
was that they kind of show like all
these
all these people down here in this
bunker kind of like arguing like what
are we gonna do and it's like you know
people are gonna die anyway maybe we
should you know we can't even
get out of here ourselves and you know
when are they going to dig us out
and uh so they kind of show them doing
that and then they kind of cut away to
some other [ __ ]
and then later they just have somebody
kind of coming across
this bunker and then they're just all
dead in there so they didn't show them
dying they didn't show they just
showed like later on yep they all died
you know what i mean but like i said
that's
that's kind of as i said what makes this
movie so scary and so effective
is that it's completely realistic to
what exactly
would happen i mean and it's terrifying
it's really really a terrifying movie
it's not
it's so there's nothing you know horror
movie about it there's nothing
you know in the sense that it's not you
know
it's not fictional obviously it seems
very real
and the fact that the actors that are in
it
uh most of them are actors um but i
think the main
uh the girl that played ruth i think her
name is karen meager if i'm pronouncing
that right
uh she had actually been in a couple of
like minor
sort of tv roles like prior to this but
she wasn't like she was super
recognizable or anything
and she went on to have a tv career
after this um you know
but a lot of the people that are in this
were just kind of people that turned up
like at a um you know at a audition uh
where very famously they told they told
all these people to come to this place
and they were just like just show up and
look really
miserable and like wear rags and stuff
that should be extras
and then they put so they put them in
the movie so i think the fact that there
is nobody recognizable in this
is like makes it way scarier because
these could just be regular [ __ ]
people
um you know it's not like oh my god
stephen steve guttenberg died in the
[ __ ]
apocalypse that's terrible it's just
like oh my god that's a person that's
just like
my next door neighbor that's a that
could be me you know what i mean so i i
feel like that was something that made
it a lot more effective
one thing too and it's interesting and i
think they were actually really really
wise to do this
is that while they do show the larger
effects
one i like that they kept it to one
city sheffield uh you know so they could
show
just the impact it was you know it was
kind of like a microcosm of what would
be happening in other cities
around the world but you only needed
this one you know you only had a few
characters to focus on so you could kind
of keep it
close to home while still showing you
know the larger effects of what would be
going on so it could make it more
relatable to the viewer because
you know obviously if you're just going
to show a mushroom cloud way over there
you know that's not really going to
affect people as much
as showing you know the the effects of
you know the
[ __ ] like the shop like next door like
the glass blowing out and
everyone being burned alive you know and
[ __ ]
so i so i think they struck a good
balance there but it was great because
there were all these just little moments
that really brought home
to you how horrific this would be and it
was just like a little silly [ __ ] it was
just like an old dude
reading a newspaper like on the can like
when the bombs fell because i said oh
that's probably what happened to me with
my
[ __ ] luck but i mean it's like it's
funny which is that was pretty much like
the only moment of
any kind of humor in this film was like
the dude like oh [ __ ] you know what i
mean
but just because like a lot of it was so
relatable because i was like holy [ __ ]
that's probably what happened like
nuclear bombs fall and i'd be sitting on
the [ __ ] toilet
but you know there's stuff like that it
was like a close-up of like a woman's
leg like she's peeing down her leg
because she's so terrified like when the
bomb hits
there's stuff like there's just really
there's one scene where like a lot of
that a lot of people have said like
really stuck with them with just this
woman
and she was just holding this burned
baby
like in her arms and she was just
staring at ruth like with these this
[ __ ] thousand yards
stare and it was like really creepy
there's like burned corpses
um you know there's like this old guy
like laying out some burned
star wars figurines there's one really
upsetting one because you guys know what
uh you know a cat lover i am
there's one like really upsetting scene
with um
with like a cat there's like fire in the
foreground and then the cat's like
rolling around as if in agony hopefully
they didn't do anything really bad to
that cat
um it was 84 so you weren't really
allowed to do that so
hopefully it was all monitored by uh you
know the proper authorities
but it really did look like that cat was
like burning alive and i was just kind
of like oh [ __ ] like that really really
bummed me out
so but it was just like really little
moments like that
you know and then there's the whole
sequence where ruth goes to this
clinic or this hospital or something
like that like looking for jimmy
and you can tell it's just like complete
chaos it's like everyone's screaming
it's like there's
just tons of people outside because
obviously everybody's hurt whether they
got hurt in the bombs they had radiation
sickness or whatever
um you know obviously the doctors and
nurses are completely overwhelmed they
don't have any medicines they don't have
any bandages they don't have
anything just people are on the floor
getting limbs cut off like with just a
rag in their mouth
and it's just kind of like the [ __ ]
worst thing ever and um so
so there's a lot of really affecting
imagery like that on affecting scenes
like that even if you don't have
a you know a deep connection with the
characters the fact that they're just
human characters who are just like you
and me
i think really sells it i mean for me it
did anyway i mean i found the movie
really really
affecting and really really upsetting
depressing
you know just really really grim also
another thing too
that i don't think the day after did was
that threads actually jumps ahead in
time
several times um you know after the
bombing and you know the initial
aftermath where everything was blown to
[ __ ] and everybody was dying radiation
poisoning and whatnot
then it jumps ahead a few months jumps
ahead a few more months uh
ruth has her baby kind of you know all
alone
in a barn somewhere the baby seems to be
okay like physically like it looks okay
then they kind of jump ahead
ten years uh where the daughter is
who they call jane although they don't
call her that in the movie but i think
that's what she's credited as
but you can see that the children that
were born
since the cataclysm are obviously
severely
um mentally challenged they can't really
they talk but they only talk in like
just one word sentences
um you know everybody just has to work
in the fields because as i said because
of the nuclear winter and
subsequent uh climate change you know
drastic climate change there is not
um you know the growing season is very
very short and if you don't just spend
all
every waking moment farming then you
know everyone's just going to starve to
death
you know at some point and and you know
there's also so many corpses they didn't
have anywhere to put them and it's just
so
disease was rampant and you know at some
point between
10 and 13 years after the cataclysm like
they're saying the uk would be down to
its medieval levels of population
most of the upcoming population would
just be
you know intellectually stunted because
of all the you know birth defects
and whatnot so it really kind of does go
into
into the long-term effects which i
thought was really really good and like
really instructive uh and as i said at
the 10-year mark when
uh when ruth actually collapses and dies
because
of all you know obviously she's got
cancer she has cataracts and stuff like
that because of the radiation sickness
and because of uh you know all of the
poisoning um you know her daughter just
kind of keeps
poking at her like work work you know
like you have to get back up and get
back out in the fields and then when she
dies
the kid just kind of looks at her like
impassively
you know what i mean because she either
because she doesn't care
or because she's so used to people dying
that it doesn't affect her or because
she doesn't understand
the enormity of it um and she doesn't
call her mom she just calls her ruth
she's like ruth ruth you know what i
mean
so it's so it's really little things
like that that are kind of
that really kind of stick with you even
more than you know stock footage of the
mushroom clouds and the explosions and
all the buildings
down and everything and as i said they
do use some stock footage in this they
do use
some stock photos of you know actual
people that had radiation poisoning and
things like that
interestingly this is interesting too
the part where they uh
you know bombed sheffield the
destruction you see
of all the buildings and everything was
absolutely real uh evidently
the producers that you know the bbc film
crew or whatever
they went to this uh one neighborhood
that the council was planning on
demolishing anyway
so they told the film crew knock
yourself out
blow it up knock it down destroy it do
whatever you want
uh because they you know no one lived
there obviously they was abandoned
and they were going to tear it down
anyway so they're just like yeah film
what you want so all the stuff you see
with all the [ __ ] busted up buildings
everything like that all completely real
uh and all the fires all completely real
they did all that stuff
you know it's just kind of one of those
happy accidents i guess where they
actually got to film the realistic
looking [ __ ] i will say that
the special effects in this it's weird
because i was reading on the wikipedia
page and it was saying how like the
radiation sickness makeup was just kind
of like oh ketchup and rice krispies and
stuff
but to me it's like in the movie it
didn't really look like that and i will
say
that uh the aforementioned you know cat
rolling around in agony thing
that looked pretty real and also a lot
of the burned corpses they showed like
in the rubble and stuff
also looked really real um if that was
special effects there's pretty damn good
special effects for 1984
just saying like some of the some of the
stuff looked uh pretty [ __ ]
grisly so uh you know good job there um
it's it's hard to tell that this was
made for only four hundred thousand
pounds that's all i'm going to say
and uh so yeah so also if if it jumping
ahead ten years
and ruth dying and you know everybody's
starving to death and everything is that
that wasn't bad enough
then it jumps ahead to 13 years later
when
jane ruth's daughter uh you know is now
a few years older obviously
and she is uh
raped so by these two guys who are
trying to steal her food
and she gets pregnant and the movie ends
on the happy happy scene
of her screaming and giving birth to a
baby which they then hand her
and she looks at and just screams and
it's like freeze frame they don't show
you what the baby looks like but you're
presuming i mean it's dead
um but you're presuming that it looks
like mutated or whatever
so that's like the happy note that this
movie ends on so like i said you
really really i think everybody should
see this movie
just so we don't ever ever like
push the big red button ever like
everybody should see this
but i can understand if you don't really
want to watch it because it is not a fun
time this is not a [ __ ] hey let's pop
some popcorn and watch threads
yeah this is one of those movies where
you it's a
it's a very very grim bleak
[ __ ] depressing ride but i
honestly i thought it was really really
well done i mean they did exactly what
they set out to do it is super effective
it's super terrifying it's super scary
it's i did not find it cheesy in the
least i feel like if i watched the day
after nowadays
you know maybe i shouldn't say this
because i haven't seen it in so long but
i feel like if i watch that nowadays it
might come off as a little cheesy this
one really did not come off as cheesy in
any
by any stretch of the imagination but i
will say if if
perhaps you wanted to do a whole uh
world-ending nuclear armageddon party uh
you you could watch threads you could
watch the day after
uh some people said there's another one
called testament which is also very good
um i think there's one called when the
wind blows i believe that one's animated
you know that's kind of along the same
lines there have been several
and as i mentioned before the war game
from 1965 that was a bbc production
which as i said i think they
subsequently did uh
air on bbc they wouldn't show it back in
the 60s but they did show it in the
early 2000s if i'm remembering it
correctly
but uh yeah if you're ever in the mood
for some gold
let's watch the entire world burn if
it's one of those kind of days
or you're kind of having a bad day and
you're just like i want to see some
people have
really like the worst day imaginable and
maybe that will make me feel better you
could certainly do worse than threads
and as i said it's available on blu-ray
uh in the u.s
and in the uk and uh at the moment at
least as of this recording it's also
available
on shutter at least in the us so i would
recommend checking it out
uh if if you like this genre of film and
it sounds like something you would be
into
it is as i said i i said that it wasn't
a horror film
in the traditional sense it's a horror
film in the sense that it's horrifying
you know what i mean eve just because
it's so [ __ ] realistic
and uh it's probably probably one of the
most upsetting
things i've ever seen and i knew what
was coming like i knew what i was
getting into because i had read various
you know pieces about it so i kind of
knew what i was getting into but yeah
i mean gotta say i don't i don't think
anybody does despair like the british
although i don't know some
some other countries might have some
truck with that but we'll see
it it just seems like they're really
really good at
not sanitizing anything or not
making everything so oh everything's
going to be okay because i feel like we
do that sometimes in the u.s
even like in the worst kind of
situations because even like most
famously you know
like british horror movies that had like
really depressing endings you know like
the descent
and uh they always oh they had to change
it you know in the u.s version so it
wasn't quite so depressing
uh which has always that's always struck
me as like very very funny
like americans have this kind of like oh
you know things are shitty it'll turn
out okay but
the british are just kind of like no
it's just gonna get worse and worse then
it's just gonna get even worse than that
don't even think that we've gotten the
worst that it could be because it can
always get worse that seems like their
their whole mantra so check it out
threads
from 1984 and i will see you on the next
one
bye